5 12 on your Tuesday Morning are the
kids who are in school get a little bit
amped up well spring break for the
school district starts Friday a perfect
time to make a splash because this
weekend Cowabunga Bay opens in Henderson
our Brian will is there live this
morning welcome to the odarc 30 Club
Ryan
thank you Nate and you know what like
like I said pool season is just around
the corner here it may not feel like it
just this morning yet we're here at
Cowabunga Bay water park here in
Henderson and I'm with Cade the general
manager and so just a few days away from
opening but there's a special event
happening tomorrow what is that that's
correct yeah we're hosting our blood
drive we partnered with American Red
Cross and Republic Services and we're
excited to have donors come in and
donate blood and the best part about it
anytime somebody gives blood they're
getting a free ticket to come back and
use any time during our 2023 season
that's awesome and exciting to hear and
including with that season so you're
also looking to hire quite a few people
for here we are we are we're very proud
to say we're Nevada's largest or Las
Vegas's largest employer of Youth so we
have to fill about a little over a
thousand positions we're well on our way
there but there's no better spot to come
hang out and spend your summer get paid
to do so here at the water park now what
could families look forward to coming up
here when you open on Saturday yeah a
lot we're kicking off Spring break with
all of our attractions so wild surf is
our signature attraction so we we
recommend guests come hang out and try
all the attractions but if you're more
of a chill Seeker rather than a thrill
seeker we've got the wave pool The Lazy
River the VIP pool so lots of food lots
of fun lots of entertainment and of
course the Sun Well you heard it from
Kate here and of course maybe wait until
we hit those 60s and 70s as Sherry said
which is coming up in the afternoon
skier later on this week so we'll see
you back here maybe a little bit later
someone may be getting back into the
water we'll see you guys I was I was
going to ask you about that Brian very
good thank you so much and we'll send
things over to Sherry